Let's recap what you've done.
You've replaced the conventional linked
list representation with one based on
arrays.
With that you're now
ready to go parallel.
To help you do that, I'm going to give
you a handy primitive called a jump.
Here's a picture of a jump.
Oh wait, sorry, wrong picture.
Let's try again.
Suppose you're looking at
a specific linked list node.
In a jump, you move the next pointer so
that it points to
the neighbor's neighbor.
So take this next pointer,
for example, and
let's replace it with a pointer
to the neighbor's neighbor.
Now, think about this for a second.
What the!
Bad billy goat!
What would happen,
if at every node in the list,
you did a jump at exactly the same time?
Let's try it and see.
So here's the list.
At every node, do a jump.
Notice what you've just done.
You've effectively split
the list into two sub lists.
As you can imagine, that's exactly what
you need to do divide and conquer.
Now if you keep doing this, these sub
lists will get shorter and shorter and
you'll get more and more of them.
Jump.
Given a set of next pointers as input,
you can perform a jump in
parallel using this algorithm.
And notice that the new algorithm puts
the jump pointers in a new output array
called N sub out.
So for each node i, we check to
see if the next pointer is nil and
if it's not, we do a jump.
By placing the output in a separate
output array, we avoid collisions and
that's what makes it
safe to use parallel for.
Okay, you're almost ready for
the parallel list ranking algorithm.
So far you've seen three ideas.
The first is to store
the list as an array pool.
The second is to recognize the list
ranking is roughly an add scan.
Of course you need to set
the right initial values.
And finally if we have a jump operation,
we can do divide and conquer.
Go ahead and put these ideas together.
You've established that a linked
list has an equivalent array pool
representation.
So when I sketch the algorithm,
I'll draw a linked list in the old
fashioned way, but you always know
that there's an array pool equivalent.
What about treating the list
ranking as an add scan?
Remember that the key idea here was to
choose the right set of initial values
at each node.
So we put a 0 at the head and
1's everywhere else.
So now we can apply the third idea
which is to use jumps to get sublists.
If you jump repeatedly, you know the sub
list will get shorter and shorter.
At the same time,
you'll be transforming this list, so
you're going to have to do something
with these initial values.
How about this,
let's maintain an invariant.
The invariant will be,
if we take any node i, and
we start at the head of its sub list,
and
then let's say we traverse the sub list,
and we add up all the values.
Then we'll get exactly the rank of i.
So for the initial values,
you can easily check that this holds.
Now suppose I've done a bunch of jumps
and I'm looking at a particular sublist.
So here I'm just in
the middle of some sublist.
And let's further suppose
that the invariant holds.
Now let's jump everywhere
simultaneously.
You'll get a list that looks like this.
Now notice what happened.
For this node here, we effectively
cut 4 out of its sublist, but
we need to maintain this invariant.
So we can't just drop the value 4,
we've got to incorporate it somehow.
An easy way to do that would
just be to absorb 4's value.
So 12 would become 16.
The way this can work is before we do a
jump from 4, we take the value of 4 and
push it to its successor.
Okay.
Let's give this a try.
Let's do one step of the update and
jump.
For the update every node pushes
its value to its successor.
Then we do the jump to
create two sublists.
And let's just repeat this process.
Push, jump,
push, jump.
Once every node is a stand
alone node you are done.
Now I already gave you
a subroutine to perform the jumps.
What about the updates?
Here's an algorithm for
just the update step, which is parallel.
So for each node i, we take its value
and we push it to the successor..
We'll do all the rights to
a separate array of ranks.
This way we can do all
these updates in parallel.
Okay.
You're now almost ready to see
the final algorithm.